and thanks for being so patient but boy
do we have a fun fun fun class for you
today we get to talk about serious
counting before we jump into that though
there are a couple quick announcements
uh the most important announcement is
that problem set one goes out today
um it's got 12 problems and there's
actually uh or sorry 11 problems and
there's an extra credit problem if you
want and we use this thing called the
problem set app uh and it's something
that I developed after teaching cs1i for
a really long time I noticed this point
in point of students would work on
problems and you'd like to get the
immediate feedback am I getting this
right
so we built the problem set out you can
see the problem you can write up your
explanation but you can also put in your
answer and check did I get the right
number uh now at the end of the day we
really care that you understand the
mathematics so we really want you to
give your explanation of how you got
that right number but you can get that
sort of validation that whatever I did
led me to the answer that was what the
TA is expected and so you can have an
idea if you're on the right track uh so
the problem set app it's a gift from us
to you uh use it have a good time we did
build it ourselves um and it does a lot
from some other cool things one of the
things that allows for is you can do
simulations like we can use probability
to build things and I can have you code
up things that can solve problems and
you can run it and test it all in this
environment it is a good time it allows
us to ask more interesting questions now
this does mean that some of your answers
will require some python if you've
programmed in Python before fantastic if
you've never programmed python before
not a problem as long as you program I'm
in a different programming language you
can also come learn about python where
you have two different python review
sessions not one not two both optional
they're both going to be on Fridays this
week and next week they'll be at 5 PM
they'll be online and they'll be
recorded with one of our fantastic Tas
so come learn about python particularly
for probability the first week will be
mostly just the semantics Python and the
next week will be a lot about python
particularly for this uh topic
now
have you ever seen a textbook kind of
beautifully written math or you look at
a handout or uh um maybe an academic
paper and there's a really beautiful
symbols and in their textbook it turns
out there's a language for how you could
write mathematics to generate these
symbols and it's a language that you'll
all become fluent in cs109 it'll be
useful if you go into research or if you
just want to go make beautiful Pro PDFs
that have some mathematics there's a
language called latex and it's pretty
straightforward it looks scary the first
time you use it you write things like
slash sum if you want that big sum
figure use the underscore to say I want
this in the subscript because the power
symbol say I want this in the
superscript and then what comes after
shows up on the right side of the sum
but it's a pretty similar simple
language it's not like python where
you'll be learning a whole new way of
communicating complicated ideas this was
just more of a markup for mathematics
there's a handout on the website that
tells you and gives you lots of examples
for latex you don't have to use it for
cs109
you can write all your answers without
latex and that'll be just fine but if
you want to learn you absolutely
couldn't not be encouraged because it'll
make your problems look more beautiful
do you grade you on beauty no but does
it feel good yeah it's like oh look at
that some simple beautiful anyways let's
talk there you go
one of the great parts of this class as
you know are sections you don't you
shouldn't have signed up for a section
yet
um because section signups will be going
out tomorrow and they'll be open until
Saturday it's not first come first serve
so don't be like waiting up till
midnight to try and like book a spot in
your favorite section instead you'll
just give us all your preferences and
then on Sunday we'll do a big matching
between uh sections and section times
I want to give you guys a guys of hey
what's our expectation
problem set for how much of an
explanation you should give and here's
the broad level you should give enough
explanation that you could teach another
student in 109 who's just about to start
the problem set how to do it with your
explanation so definitely don't leave
your explanation blank that will not
give you full credit don't just write
one sentence but write a you know maybe
a couple sentences to show somebody the
idea that you use to get to your answer
and you know it should be in that level
of detail something that if we took your
explanation and put a little section in
a textbook that explanation should fit
into something like a course reader for
cs109 does that sound good
okay so explain your work if you do a
reasonable job we are not going to be
overly intense about it just do the
explanation uh and I think you we will
all be good on that front
uh Honor Code you know we have to talk
about it you guys probably want to
understand what the honor code means for
cs109 honestly if you
feel like you are not cheating the
system you're probably doing it right
but there are explicit rules that uh we
list on the website and you know maybe
one of the things that is pretty obvious
is like don't look for the answer from
past quarters uh don't ask somebody in a
different part of the world to do the
the problem set up for you and don't
give the answers to somebody else in the
class but maybe you do want to make
friends in this class you do want to
work on problems together we absolutely
encourage this we would love for you
guys to make friends and work on these
things together where do we draw the
line well you can work on the problems
you can talk about the problems but you
all have to write up your own Solutions
so everybody writes up their own
Solutions and that's where we'd like to
draw the line for the honor code if you
have any questions ask us or the Tas
okay late policy
you know what I want you guys to learn
this I want you to all walk out of this
class have you master this material if
you feel like that would be better
achieved if you take a small break at
some point in the quarter absolutely
fine with me I want you to get there by
the end of the quarter so I came up with
a late period that gives you as much a
late policy that gives you as much power
as possible so here's how it works there
will be a due date for problems that's
because we're Tas are students too we
need to grade we need to be able to give
you guys feedback so there has to be a
due date for problem sets that due date
for problem sets though let's say you
just miss it by five minutes
we don't give you a zero on the problem
side so what instead what we do is we
give everybody a free grace period in
fact instead of five minutes we say Okay
up to 24 hours after that due date if
you submit it we will take it
and you can use that for things like oh
I just needed to sleep in a little bit
longer or I just missed the deadline now
that's a very harsh cutoff after 24
hours there will be a computer moderated
moment when it's no longer in the grace
period now if you missed the grace
period do we give you a zero no
we're going to allow you to give
yourself long extensions in cs109 and a
long extension is about two class
periods
if you take a long extension not a
problem for us we'll still be able to
grade your assignments on time the thing
is it could be a problem for you because
109 is a fast-paced class like while
you're taking that extension we're
moving on with material and then the
next problems that's going to come so
fast we know how hard time management is
at Stanford or if you're new to Stanford
hey quarter system's a crazy Beast so
you can give yourselves this extension
but we want you to be thoughtful about
how you're going to catch up and you can
do this two times in the quarter and you
don't really need our permission we just
want you to log your plan for catching
up and if you need more than two times
in a quarter you just let us know
if you need an extension longer than
this there is a small logistic problem
which is we will have already released
the solutions and we'll already have
started grading generally we don't take
extensions past this 120 hour mark or
what we call the super late extension
and if you need one if you're in that
situation talk to us as soon as possible
and we'll talk to like academic
directors we'll come up with like a
bigger plan to get you back on track for
cs1 it's not like if you miss this
you're out of the class but we do need
to have a more serious conversation if
you can't make that very late extension
so basically I give you all the power to
control your life in cs109
okay
the problem said man made with love for
you guys but it's pretty nudes I've used
it in only one quarter before this uh we
made it last winter we think it's very
robust you know it's gone through a
whole course but you might see something
that uh is surprising if you guys find
any bugs I would really appreciate to
know and I'll fix it as soon as humanly
possible
um and I'll appreciate you guys letting
me know because we'd like to make a
beautiful tool for a future cs109 to use
as well
okay oh and then some of you have this
desire to hack things I think we're
pretty hack proof but uh I just slightly
say what if we try to hack it after the
quarter because then it doesn't look
like academic dishonesty uh so if you
want to try and figure out ways that you
can poke around and break the problem
set up that'd be fantastic but like
let's wait until you know final exam is
done
uh okay and then I put one problem on
the problem set which is requires a bit
of creativity to solve so it'll be the
very fast oh if it'll be the very last
boo
the very last problem on the first
problem set it's a
oh there's an extra credit problem
sorry my internet's not very good and
Huang
which is not that important there's an
extra credit problem you don't have to
do it but if you want to just challenge
yourself and try and do something
creative interesting there have at it
there's a cool problem for you wow
that's a lot of logistics I guess we're
still at the beginning of the quarter
and there's a lot of things to talk
about any questions about this before I
move on
yeah
oh yeah for that one I want to I want
you to get the right answer that's a
good question generally you know
actually that's a great question because
it applies to everything else like in
cs19 if you don't get the right answer
we generally give you partial credit
whether it's a problem set midterm or
final we generally give you partial
credit but for this extra credit one I
really want to see people get the right
answer in fact because the right answer
is very obvious it's how you get to the
right answer that's more interesting
um good good question
okay
yeah
because I read through the syllabus and
it wasn't very clear uh like what see so
what is the
um problem sets each week how do we
submit them like if we hit check answer
does that mean it's like submitted or
what oh my gosh so such a good question
um the problem set app is continuously
submitting like when you're programming
it's on our server there's no point
hitting submit we already have it and so
it will just stay open until like at one
moment the the the deadline will pass
and then you won't be able to edit
anymore so as long as you're editing
we're getting it
um so
oh it's just Placebo
yeah click it and I think it says a
message like this didn't actually submit
it because you're constantly submitting
uh so very good question uh
yeah and when you hit check answer yes
all everything does get automatically
put on our database so if you hit check
answer we know that you've got that
green check mark II
okay and then there is one last thing
for today uh if you go to cs109
and you go to lecture two
oh man my lecture my internet is really
slow
are you guys finding internet slow too
good oh well
um anyways there is a way that you can
go follow along with the Press questions
for lecture two but one of the questions
for lecture two is just the first
question just says presence
serious
uh and it says what is the word written
on the board and the answer is purple
zebra
you can put this into the problem set
app anytime between now and five o'clock
and I'll know you're in lecture and the
idea here is I have thought a lot about
this and I know that coming to lecture
is such a good thing for you it's a good
thing for you it's a good thing for the
class like trying to stay on top of a
fast-paced Stanford class without going
to the synchronous lectures is a very
hard task I've been a student and I
failed at doing that at one point in my
career I've seen lots of people try and
some are successful but by and large I
know that coming to lecture is a good
thing for you it's also a good thing for
your friends like coming here and having
community of learning what a beautiful
thing
so you don't have to come to lectures
optional you get 100 in the class if you
don't but if you do come to lecture and
you know you fill in the word on the
board uh every single class or for most
of them so like for 90 of the classes
I'll take five percent off your final
exam and I'll just give you a full
credit for that and so it's just a way
to incentivize you to come to lecture
but an optional one don't take it it's
not a problem if you feel like you can
do the final exam without coming to any
lectures not a problem at all
does that sound cool trying something
out that's new if you guys have
questions about it please do let me know
uh no most most States
you're great at the end of the day and
I'll say is your grade better because
you just like Rock the Final or is your
grade better because you came to many
lectures I'll choose whichever one's the
Max and I'll give you guys the max of
those two greats that was a fantastic
question
more questions
okay
yeah
um if I type something into
oh never mind
you don't have to do this now if you
don't have a computer that's not a
problem I'll just have a sheet at the
end of the day you can come in all right
at the end of class and you can come
write down your name so if you don't
have a computer that's actually a great
thing
um as well
okay
exciting
but not as exciting as counting so cs109
we're going to build this beautiful
edifice of knowledge and it all starts
with the very humble beginnings of
counting and online in last class we
learned about the two most fundamental
rules of counting from which all the
theories of counting are derived and
from which the theory of probability
Finds Its Origins we learned about
counting with steps you want to count
the number of exp outcomes to a
particular experiment well if you break
it up into different steps
if it happens to be a case that the
number of outcomes from one step doesn't
change how many outcomes are to Future
steps you can just multiply the number
of outcomes in each steps together to
get the total number of outcomes in the
experiment
you can take a big counting problem and
you can break it into smaller ones if
you can find steps that could construct
outcomes of the type you're looking at
that's one core idea in counting and the
other core idea of counting is if we're
trying to count number of outcomes to
experiment
if we can think of those number of
outcomes and we can split it into
outcomes either come from group a or
they come from Group B we can use this
or method of counting in which case you
say let's count how many outcomes are
from group a let's count how many
outcomes are from Group B let's add
those together and then let's subtract
off how many outcomes are in both groups
because it's possible for some outcomes
to be in both groups and if you didn't
subtract this out you would be double
counting and that's where we left off
those are the two core ideas and we're
going to play with them a lot today
we solved a whole bunch of problems in
fact this was a nice one if you had to
choose one problem to review from
problem set or from lecture one to make
sure you understand both those I think
it's this one because here we construct
strings that either start with a zero
one or end with a one zero and we use
both ideas we say we're going to count
number of strings that are one two three
four five six digits long they can
either come from set a which starts with
zero one or they can come from set B
which ends with one zero
there are some elements that are in both
sets and we can just add those up and
subtract off the over counting but in
order to construct each of these sets we
could use the step rule of counting like
if you want to figure out how many
strings start with zero one you could
say okay the steps to create a six digit
string is two zero one then you have two
choices for this bit two for this bit
two for this bit two for this bit it's a
five step process step one there's only
one choice choose these two bits step
two step three step four step five
so we can use step processes to
construct our strings but we can also
use the oral counting together in one
problem what a beautiful thing and at
the end of class
we looked at this problem which we're
going to go a little bit deeper into
today
okay
these are the core building blocks but
there's a lot of canonical problems in
counting and these canonical problems
show up in probability as well so it's
worth knowing them just because they're
a beautiful natural occurrence in our
world but also because they're useful
for understanding to the topic of
today's class
so we talked about this a little bit at
the end of class how many letter
orderings are possible of the following
string that is c-h-r-i-s and the way we
thought about this was we can use the
step rule of counting here's all the
orderings so when we say we're counting
number of outcomes we want to say how
many things are on this screen
each outcome is a distinct construct
we're not doing the task of enumerating
all the distinct constructs we're doing
the task of counting how many there are
but the Step rule of counting says what
are the steps that you could have used
to construct one of these answers so
what are the steps that could be used to
end up with curse or uh hit occur
something like that
and here's steps that we talked about
step one choose your first letter
there's five choices for that
after you choose your first letter
there's four left for your second letter
no matter what your first choice was
there's always going to be four for a
second and then you'll have three left
over and two left over and one left over
you can have a five step process to
choose all of your letters so you can
say there's a five step process one of
the outcomes could have been choosing H
which leaves four outcomes left for the
next letters because you could use c s i
or R and you repeat this and we have a
step construction of our outcomes
because we've been able to break this
into steps and because it has the
property that the choice of one step
doesn't affect how many outcomes you
have in future steps we can use the step
rule of counting and it's five times
four times three times two times one and
in fact this problem construct comes up
so much that has a special name and
people write down the definition in
textbooks and they call it permutations
permutations we're going to consider any
ordered arrangement of objects so if you
think of every character as an object
and you think of a string as an ordering
of those characters you can see how your
unique strings are in fact orderings of
objects
if all of your objects are distinct so
all your letters are different then it's
just going to be n and this isn't like
really loud n this is n factorial which
means n times n minus 1 times M minus
two
um going on until one
and that's the unique number of
orderings
so let's warm ourselves up uh how many
unique six digit passcodes are possible
on a phone which uses each of six
distinct numbers and my story for you is
you're the FBI you found this phone and
it's got smudges on exactly six of the
numbers
so you know that they're using these six
numbers for their passcodes you just
don't know what the order is and how
many possible passcodes would you have
to try to try all possible passcodes
that uses each of those six smudges take
a moment say hi to the person next to
you see if you can think about this
problem
okay
anyone have an idea of how we can
approach this I know that's not enough
time but we got a lot of cool stuff to
do today
we have like not that many rules we've
learned today we've learned permutations
so guess what it is just factorial it's
a permutation yeah exactly it is
factorial uh and and I guess the idea
here is what are the objects that you're
ordering
yeah the numbers and are they all
distinct
and we want an ordering so if you have
objects they're all distinct you want an
ordering you can use the rule of
permutations so the number of distinct
orderings of distinct objects is going
to be factorial and there's one two
three four five six distinct objects so
it's going to in fact be six factorial
so 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 which is there's 720 passcodes
to check
and I think your iPhone starts to shut
down after you've tried like five
okay
um
so there's an another question that I
think is interesting for Illuminating
this how this thought process could be
used in a similar problem that's
slightly different
what if I said how many unique passcodes
are possible if the phone password is
some ordered subset of any six digits so
now forget the smudges
you just say passcodes have six digits
in them
how many ways could you make a six digit
passcode if
you say that each of the numbers have to
be different
so in this case you know there's six
digits so there's
10 choices for your first number nine
choices for your second if you say that
each of the numbers have to be different
eight choices for your third seven
choices for your fourth six choices for
your fifth and five choices for your
last one uh and then after this point
you have a step rule that has
constructed a six digit password
where each of your numbers are distinct
uh and in this case you know we don't
keep going through the full factorial
because our passcodes are only of length
sixth not of length ten if you wanted
all the orderings of ten numbers that
are of length 10 is 10 factorial but if
you want of length six you know at some
point you stop and you don't get the
full factorial instead you get the
factorial uh divided by all those ones
you didn't count so four times three
times two times one
okay
so
here's my question for you though
we've talked about how you can order
objects if they are distinct but it
turns out this project gets problem gets
a lot more interesting if you allow for
some of your objects to be indistinct
so for example if I said you know order
the numbers one two three four five we
could just use five factorial
but the problem breaks down if some of
those numbers are indistinguishable from
one another and why is that you know in
one of your orderings
you'll get one one zero zero zero in
this case but in a different ordering
you could get one one zero zero zero
because if you think of these two ones
as indistinct you'll have an ordering
where these two ones are flipped and
these don't actually look any different
so if some of your objects are
indistinct there's not five times four
times three times two times one options
for orderings there's something a little
bit less
in order to teach you how to drive this
I'd like to tell you a story of Coke
cans
and it speaks to a strategy that we use
in counting but we also use in
probability a lot instead of ordering
ones and zeros I'm gonna be ordering my
Coke ones and my Coke Zeros yet again
this is the exact same problem I'd like
to know how many ways are there of
ordering these cans but the coke series
are indistinguishable from each other
and the coke ones are indistinguishable
making sense
here's the trick here's the pro tip and
you're going to use this Pro tip a lot
in counting even though they're
indistinguishable we're going to make
them fancy
we're going to make them be
distinguishable just for a moment as a
first step in our derivation so I'm
going to take these boring Coke cans and
I'll make them I'm name them after all
my friends so I got Aisha can I got the
Tim can I got the arena can I got the
Joey can I got the Wadi can uh and there
now I took these indistinct objects and
I gave them personality they are now all
distinct
and because I've done this I've kind of
brought it into this land of a solution
space we understand so if all your Coke
cans are distinct
then solving number of orderings becomes
easy again
you know it's just permutations if we
think about how many ways you can order
these distinct cans five options for
your first can four options for your
second time you guys are starting to see
this pattern right
so there's five factorial ways of
ordering them if they're distinct
but now you say
Chris they're not distinct and because
of that you've over counted you know
there's the time where you have this
like the one Coke can that is for uh
Irina
and there's the one Coke can that's for
Aisha and you're thinking about these
two different orderings as being the
same or as being distinct from each
other
so we kind of have we've done this
simplification but we have to fix all of
our double Counting
so I have a task for you guys
I want to count how many Coke cans there
are
how many unique orderings there are I've
made all my Coke cans distinct and I
said that there's five factorial ways of
counting those distinct ones and I'm
telling you I've over counted but I have
this challenge for you is think how many
times I've over counted take a moment
talk to the person next to you first see
if you can make sure that you both
understand the question and then see if
you can figure out a way to figure out
how many times I have over counted by
making them all distinct talk to the
person next to you let's see if we can
solve this very hard problem together
okay let's just try a thought process
if there's a 120 different ways of
ordering five distinct items
but I'm claiming not all of our things
are distinct three of the zeros are
indistinguishable from one another and
two of the ones are indistinguishable do
you guys think the total number is going
to be larger or smaller just yell it out
loud
yeah okay that's good
um that's a good smoke test so it's
going to be smaller we've over counted
in some way if you've over counted in
some way there's two ways you could have
over counted
you could have over counted by a fixed
number of ways like maybe there's five
or of these orderings that somehow break
the rule and you just need to find those
five and then subtract out the number
five
there's a different way of over counting
there's a way of over counting where you
have a multiple of over countings like
for example double counting would be for
every unique outcome
you've shown it's shown up exactly twice
in your count of 120. and those are two
different mechanisms of double counting
it turns out in this case we've done the
second one
so
if we think about some of these as
indistinct
there's a couple ways that we could
think about solving this and in fact you
know one of the ways
one of the approaches for understanding
this is you could say I've got my 120
outcomes each of those outcomes look
like this where you have you know an
ordering of your ones and zeros but we
think of them as distinct
for every single outcome
you could take the eyes and you could
switch their places and you would find
exactly one duplicate of that outcome
does that make sense so for all the eyes
we've double counted we can take this
120 and we can divide it by two
but then you'll also find some
situations where they'll look the same
but the distinct version will have
different subscripts on the zeros
divided by two solves the problem that
the subscripts on the eyes might lead to
in distinct things being looking like
distinct but we haven't solved the zeros
how many ways have we overcounted once
we start thinking about the zeros
does that one come up with an idea while
we were talking
yes um
so for those three you're basically like
how many you look at how many ways there
are to order those three independent of
how you've ordered the other two and
then that's three factors
yeah so that's a oh great oh by the way
that was really funny you didn't raise
your hand but the person next to it was
like that guy knows which I really
appreciate
um so for any ordering of the zeros you
can imagine within our data set you'll
see a version of this string where you
see Zero with all these different
subscripts in every permutation possible
in every ordering possible so you'll get
wtj wjt all three factorial permutations
will show up in this format
so it turns out we've also over counted
by the number of ones or all the number
of zeros that are indistinct that we
treat as distinct all the different
orderings of those so in fact this
should be 120 divided by two times three
factorial
there's a second way you could get this
insight
and this is a little bit nuanced but
this shows the derivation for the rule
we just used so if you want to get away
from intuition you just like want cold
hard math rules this is a way you could
have derived it
you could have said I want to think of
this two-step process that creates all
the permutations of distinct objects
let me give you a two-step operation
that will lead to permutations of
distinct objects
your first step is
make all the permutations where some of
your objects are interesting so all the
permutations of zeros where zeros are
indistinct in all the permutations of
one where ones are Instinct this is the
target we're looking for that's the
thing we're trying to count but that's
the first step in this two-step process
first you make those and then as your
second step you find a way to switch out
the zeros and ones you choose some
ordering for the actual subscripts the
eyes and the A's and then after you
chose this orderings for the subscripts
you choose the orders for the subscripts
of the second uh in distinct group
so this is a two-step process that
describes how you can get all the
permutations of distinct objects we're
not trying to calculate the permutations
of distinct objects we're trying to
calculate how many things are in this
step
but those are guys who are fans of
multiplication division know that like
oh I can just get you cheekily over
there
and then you have a way to calculate the
permutations where some of your objects
are indistinct that's the situation we
have you know some of the zeros are
indistinct and the ones are indistinct
is you just count how many permutations
there are Imagine they're all distinct
and they have to divide out how many
ways you could permute each of the
groups of indistinct objects so again
that would lead to 120 so that's
um
five factorial divide by two factorial
times three factorial I forgot a
factorial here is that a problem
like that derivation suggests that this
should have been two factorial did I
make a mistake
thank God and it's because two factorial
is in fact equal to two because two
times one
is Dusty okay
this leads to a general rule so the
general rule is let's say we want to
count orderings of objects and not all
the objects are distinct you have
different subcategories of
indistinguishable objects like N1 of
your objects are the same and two are
same in a different way and and are the
same in an earth way
the rule is the total number of
permutations are
n factorial divided by N1 factorial
times n two factorial up to NR factorial
okay
last class I gave you guys this teaser
at the end of class I said how many
different orderings are there of the
word Mississippi you now have the rule
confirm it with the person next to you
make sure you understood this very
important rule in counting how many
orderings are the there of the letters
m-i-s's i-s-s-i-p-p-i go for it
okay
you know there's an art form to
mathematics
especially as you get into higher level
mathematics like where do you go from
cs109 like what's the next step in your
mathematical Journey you'll learn a few
more classes but you're getting closer
to the Forefront of you know what humans
know and if you take math beyond that
Forefront so much of it is creativity so
much of it is taking the real world
finding mathematical constructs and
either recognizing that they're already
solved problems or realizing you've
discovered an unsolved mathematical
problem that you can work on so there's
this art form mathematics of somebody
gives you a construct like this and you
have to formalize it and that's very
similar to what my day-to-day life looks
like when I'm doing research in math
it's hard though I mean in this case
maybe we only have a few tools but as
you add more and more tools it can be a
hard task and that's one of your
learning goals in cs109 not just knowing
the formulas but knowing how you can see
the mathematical structure in the
natural world
okay so you're like what's natural about
the string Mississippi well you know
we're at the beginning of cs19 it gets
more and more natural
Mississippi how many letters are there I
actually don't know but I think it's
like 11.
okay woohoo so how many orders are those
letters there's 11 factorial am I right
yeah
I'm sorry I guess that was really cheeky
of me uh yes there are in fact 11
factorial orderings of the letters
but if you did 11 factorial it would
give you every ordering and it's
thinking about these s's as being
different from one another so you'll get
an ordering where like these two s's are
in the different order and that doesn't
actually look like a different word
I've over counted how many times have I
over counted
someone help me out here
four wait where did four come that is
magical where did this come from
oh there's four S's and all the S's look
indistinct so I've over counted because
for every true unique ordering you'll
get every permutation of those
indistinct s's okay great what else have
I overcounted am I done
okay there are
you getting the four eyes Okay four eyes
and then how many M's are there
is it gonna mess it up if I put in a one
factorial here no divided by one doesn't
matter at all but you know what I feel
like including you m welcome to the
party okay who else gets included in the
party
oh and do I just do p factorial here
ah silly uh I think there's two peas
yeah feeling good
and have I gotten them all
okay there you go now you can know how
you can do orderings of Mississippi is
this important to know how many organs
are there were the Mississippi yes no
I'm just joking but is the mechanism of
how we derived it important because it
applies to lots of problems in further
mathematics absolutely permutations
especially the Instinct objects show up
a lot in fundamental theories but it's
you know fun party fact
Okay so
in this case 11 factorial divided by
four factorial four factorial two
factorial uh there's 34 000 different
orderings of those letters
okay uh
now
I do want to show you because you're
computer scientists one of the things
that you can do as a computer scientist
if you're finding any of this stuff hard
you have the power of computers we're
talking about counting how many outcomes
there are so if we say we want all the
orderings of the words Boba we want to
know how many of those are we don't have
to construct each one but as a computer
scientist one of your ways to solve this
would be to write some code that
constructs every single ordering
and python has a beautiful tool called
permutations and if you call
permutations on any list
it will construct every permutation of
the elements in that list
in this case I put that through a set
and then I just print out everything in
the set I do some pretty printing this
is a little bit of advanced python
except for this line
and maybe the fact that this function
exists you know if some of this code is
looking novel to you come to Friday's
review session we're going to talk all
about python it's a beautiful thing but
it's also the language of pseudocode so
if you don't know python uh hopefully
this is making sense take my letters get
every single permutation and then print
them out so you can use the power of
python to help you out this would be a
really really long way of finding out
that there are 4 factorial divided by
two ways of solving this here's this the
shorter way of counting how many
outcomes there are you can say python
what's four factorial python what's two
factorial Python's like it's two but
Python's so polite it's never a
condescending it'll just give you back
two very politely and they'll get four
factorial divided by two and you get the
answer much quicker
okay so now you know a little bit of
code
here are all the formulizations of tasks
we're going to do so what we've just
talked about is how you can sort objects
and you've got to become really good at
counting orderings of objects and you
might feel like is that the only task
counting people care about no we care
about other things like objects or
choosing objects and putting things in
buckets you're like do you care about
other things like your family's like no
I just care about these three tasks no
I'm kidding
um
uh let's talk about some other tasks
oh and actually though I do want to give
us one more challenge because even
though we're going to talk about
canonical tasks I want you to always
return to those two rules we learned
last class the step rule of counting and
the two uh the or rule of counting
because those are your building blocks
it's easy to take a problem that's
slightly different from a permutation
problem where you have to combine those
building blocks with canonical things
like permutations let me give you an
example we're going to go back to our
trusty old phone and now instead of
having six smudges there are five
smudges it is still a length six
password
so my question for you is if there's
five smudges how many unique passwords
could exist and this is just an example
of why you want to know those
fundamental rules in addition to the
generalized formulas like permutations
you guys want to get to know that person
next to you this is a little challenging
but think about it and it's certainly
solable with the tools you have five
smudges six digit passcodes how could we
possibly do this okay let's get amongst
okay
I often ask you some pretty hard
questions in lecture
this is a pretty hard one what I'm going
to do in lectures I'm going to show you
lost six examples and that way you'll
get some intuitions you know when I look
at a math problem I'm not starting from
scratch I have seen many many math
problems solved they live somewhere in
my brain so I see a new problem I kind
of do some sort of pattern matching I I
do think about the problems I've seen
before so in lecture I'm going to show
you lots of examples I'll ask you to
solve them like you're seeing it for the
very first time and that's hard I all I
ask of you is that you engage with it
you get your mind amongst it because if
you get your mind amongst it even if you
don't derive this really hard problem on
the spot when you do see the derivation
you'll be a little bit more ready for it
because you'll at least appreciate the
difficulties so whether or not you got
the answer let's talk about it together
I also have a pro tip for you guys let's
say you're working on a problem set
starting today
um when you're working on the problems
that there'll be a lot of counting
problems and sometimes you'll look at
County problem like this one and it will
look daunting
a first step if you find anything hard
is to start writing examples of outcomes
you're counting like it's really
abstract what we're counting here but if
I make concrete outcomes it becomes a
little clearer okay I'm counting all of
these different outcomes you know what
your outcomes look like
one of the reasons that's also helpful
is if you use the step rule of counting
you're explaining steps that could
generate each of your outcomes
So speaking of which what are steps that
could generate each of these outcomes
okay an idea choose the five numbers
and then choose which you know that you
need to use all five because of the
smudges so exactly one must be repeated
do you choose which one you repeat then
you choose the two slots
in some in the sequence where you use
that repeated number and then you
preview the rest of them okay that says
step one we know there's exactly one
digit that will be repeated
your first step is to choose that digit
to repeat how many choices do you have
you could choose to repeat the two you
could choose to repeat the four the five
the six or the eight all those are good
choices for the digit that gets repeated
that's our first step does that
construct an outcome no it just chooses
a digit we need to continue our
construction ways
your step two is to generate the
passcode you now have four distinct
objects
and two indistinct objects you know
there's one number which is repeated and
there's four numbers that occur exactly
once
so if you have six objects four of them
are distinct and two of them look
indistinct how many ways could you order
those six objects
yeah just say it out wow what are you
thinking
he has louder much louder
it's okay if you talk over each other
this one okay okay but I really
appreciate the the uh that you guys
don't want to talk over each other uh
six factorial
but six factorial over counts the fact
that two of them are indistinct and you
need to divide by that two factorial
just like we were doing over here so
there's six factorial ways of ordering
your digits divided by two factorial to
deal with the over counting
so there's five choices for the double
digit and then your next step is to take
those things that you've set out on your
table and actually come up with an
ordering and there's six factorial
divide by two factorial so this combines
a rule we just learned
into the step rule of counting so we're
going to show you these canonical rules
but always remember your your two most
fundamental ones the step rule of
counting and the or rule of counting
okay so at this point you guys are old
enough and you guys are wise enough to
learn about Combs uh combinations
combination is a different counting task
in this different counting task we're
going to take objects and we're going to
choose
some subset of them so you know my
example that we're going to run with is
eventually going to be
I give I have five books here
I want to figure out how many ways could
I choose three of them and you can start
thinking about that
but I'm going to tell you guys a story
I'm going to tell you guys a story and
it's going to show us how we can solve
all the problems in this space
and it involves cake
a delicious thing in fact actually I
have a one and a half year old right she
discovered cake like two weeks ago and
it's like deep in our psyche she like
had that she's like that is good stuff
and like ever since she's like how about
more cake and we're like What if we ate
dinner she's like no more cake so going
on that Vibe let's learn about counting
of combinations using cake
we're going to have a party and this
party there's going to be 20 people but
this isn't a very nice party we're only
going to give five people cake you're
like what sort of awful like diabolical
human being are you ha ha ha ha ha
so this is the task of choosing a subset
so you have 20 people are going to
choose a subset of five to give cake
can I tell you a story of how we could
come up with every different way we
could give five people cake
we could say here is a generative story
and generative story is invoking the
step rule of counting I'm going to show
you steps that could lead to an outcome
where we've given exactly five people
cake
we get all the people in our party in a
line also not a good thing to do at a
party
then after that we're going to say hey
everybody in this line has an ordering
they have a location in the line and
we're going to take those first five
people and we're gonna give them cake
like you awful awful person give
everyone cake
so we got n people in line how many ways
can we do that well it depends if people
are distinct are people distinct
of course no two people are alike we're
all individuals we all have our own
hopes and wants and dreams in this wild
world we're all distinct so is
permutations of distinct objects there's
n factorial of them
step two
there's only one way of doing step two
is to draw a line after the first person
and it's going to say every person in
the front of this line welcome to the
cake room
and there's only one way of doing this
uh this next step
but now that we put all these cake room
we're gonna give them cake
but if you think about an outcome where
these five people get cake it doesn't
really matter which order they're
standing in they all get cake
and so they could be this way in the
room they could be at a different
permutation room any permutation still
leads to exactly those five distinct
people getting caked so imagine the next
step is I'm going to let all these
people in the room chill and intermingle
and enjoy their cake and so they can go
spread out and we're gonna say they can
when they intermingle there's gonna be
five factorial ways that they could
intermingle uh within this group so if
my next step is to let them intermingle
you know there's five factorial ways of
doing that next step
now all these other people who are not
in the cake room they've also not gotten
cake but in this construction I've
chosen these five people to get cake
I've chosen these uh 15 people not to
get cake but I'll have an outcome for
every ordering of these 15 people even
though in that outcome this exact set of
15 people didn't get cake I've over
counted by 15 factorial in my last step
I have to let these people who are not
in the cake room I have to let them
intermingle now if n is the total number
of people and K is the number of people
who got cake there's nysk factorial ways
that I could let these people
intermingle
and then you're like I'm not an awful
person so I'm like just kidding you guys
all get cake and not even cake to
everybody and then we like have a party
and we're like why are we in different
rooms we should all be in the same room
having this blast of a party and
everyone's like yeah cake no dinner for
us for adults we get to make our own
choices
what have I done here
any story
I want to give you a deep idea for where
the rule comes from for counting ways
that you could give K or you could
choose Cape a subset of size K from a
group of size n
formally outside of the world of K we
call this a combination so if you have K
objects you want to choose a subset of n
we're going to call that a combination
and the rule for combination is the
number of ways that you could do that
the ways you could take your 20 people
and choose five to get cake would be 20
factorial
but then you have to divide out the five
people in the room with cake and you
have to divide out the 15 people in the
room without cake because if you think
about this as an ordering of that line
of people
it doesn't not every of those ordering
is a distinct assignment of cake to
people so we've counted by this many
times and the derivation was you know n
factorial ways to line people up one way
to put the cake not cake split uh
there's K factorial people in the cake
room they need to not worry about
ordering and there's nysk people who are
not in the k group we also not need to
not worry about ordering so we can have
this one two three four step process
that could generate an or a particular
assignment of a chosen
take people out of your set of n
you should know that derivation because
it's fun and interesting and I think
it's Illuminating and it can teach us
things about probability but you can
also just know this General canonical
process if you want to choose a subset
of size K from a group of n you can just
use this equation
now this equation shows up so much in so
many distinct parts of mathematics that
it gets its own notation you might see
this it's called the binomial
coefficient nothing we've talked about
has anything to do with binomial
distribution but it turns out the
coefficients if you had to set up a
binomial equation end up having weights
that can be derived using this formula
as well there's lots of parts of
mathematics where this exact calculation
shows up
so we have the special notation for it
and if you see a problem and you can
understand it as choosing a subset you
can just use this equation
quick check
in this problem formulation are all your
objects assumed to be distinct or
indistinct
distinct think about your people they're
all different Unique Individuals if you
want to choose three items from a set of
ten and they're all indistinct
many ways are there of doing that
yeah
because if they're all interesting it's
like you have 10 Coke hands you choose
three you've got I have three Coke cans
and no matter how you choose three
cocains it looks exactly like three
cookouts there's only one unique outcome
so if everything is Instinct this
problem is actually not that interesting
uh so we are Marching right along now I
told you as a motivating example of this
not to think about cake but to think
about a slightly more realistic problem
say I have these five lovely textbooks I
have the course textbook do you know the
course has a textbook it's a really good
resource if you want to go even deeper
into some of the stuff humans in New
York they tell stories mostly humans
mostly in New York
the definition of everything in
mathematics quite a small book
I like this book it's called the theory
that would not die
it's about Bayes theorem and how Bayes
theorem allowed you know Turing to break
the Enigma in World War II how it kept
showing up in the 90s in the revolution
mathematics that came from the computer
science departments and how it continues
to influence thinkers in fact a few of
the papers I've written in new
algorithms have in fact used this old
old idea called base theorem where could
you learn about Bayes theorem
in this
how cool is that and this is really
one student took the course reader and
published it into like a hard book which
is like kind of funny thing there's only
one copy in the world so I'll fight you
to the death over it or maybe I'd lend
it to you let's say there's six distinct
books and I want to choose three
uh
how many ways could I do that and to be
clear if I give you these three books do
you care if I give it to you like this
or like this or like this no it's the
same three books you just care that I
gave you these three books as opposed to
these three books so in this problem
type we don't care about ordering we
just care about what was chosen so
there's a combination choosing three
books out of six
take a moment instead of talking person
next to you think about it you're like
hmm do we have a rule for this
like yeah
you don't have to go to the Kate
derivation you could be like okay
I'm gonna get all my books in a line I'm
gonna draw a cut off at three then I'm
gonna let these go into room and permute
I'm gonna get these uh remaining
two to go into another room in preview
and then I have five factorial divided
by three factorial divided by two
factorial you don't have to go to that
origin story you could good times or you
could just say I recognize this as a
combination problem all my items are
distinct
and I'm choosing a set of three from a
set of six so there's in fact just six
choose three ways
so you can say this is six choose three
which is the same as six factorial
divide by three factorial divide by
three factorial
uh 20 ways
okay
so
here's another instance of this problem
and this is going to be a sub problem
it's something you'll see in your
problem set so worth paying attention to
I have myself here a deck of cards it is
a standard deck of cards except that
they're awesomely large a lot of games
involve getting a hand of size of five
cards and in this hand of five cards it
does not matter the size of the cards it
does not matter the ordering the cards
but it does matter which of the cards
you get
all the cards in a deck of cards are
unique if you didn't know they all have
a unique combination of number and suit
and so this is different from say this
hand and if you want to do mathematics
around gambling and much of probability
was invented by people who are horribly
addicted to gambling and they're
inventing probability so that they could
beat their friends you would have to be
able to count how many different hands
of cards are possible so you have a deck
of 52 cards how many ways could you get
say five cards
and at this point you're like I know
this I'm starting to get comfortable
with combination things I'm starting to
see this in many problems in the world
uh this is in fact a combination
now if you want to calculate that
combination you can just say in Python
you can ask the question hey what is 52
factorial divided by 5 factorial divided
by 52 minus 5 factorial let me go to the
code for a second
uh and I have myself here
a video server the problem set app and
over here
is a way to count how many unique hands
there are in cards
so check out this python
I'm going to first do this the long way
and then I'm going to do this the short
way
in the long way I'm going to construct a
deck of cards with 52 different cards
I'm going to take for every value and
for every suit I'm going to get every
combination afterwards there'll be 52
elements in my list of cards these three
four lines just create a deck of cards
I told you that python has this thing
called inner tools you can also say give
me every combination
if I say enter tools give me every
single combination it will give me every
combination of the cards of size five
it'll give it to me as a list and I can
print out the length of this list
uh let's just run that because what a
good time
count hands
and it says there are 2.6 million
unique uh choices of five cards from all
your 52 cards if you wanted to as a
computer scientist you could actually
look at what each of those are
um so for hand
in subsets
you could print out each hand one at a
time
and if I do this
every single line here will show up
exactly one so it'll be one unique
choice of cards how many times is this
program gonna run
or how many lines is going to print out
2.5 million that's too long I am not
patient for that
um so I want to use this as a chance to
enumerate the difference between we're
counting versus we're going to generate
each of the outcomes in this part of
cs109 we are just counting how many
things you have to do
instead of creating all of these cards
though
we could have just done this we could
say you know how many hands there are we
can do
either you can ask python what is 52
choose five and well hey
they're not safe I always forget to save
we've all been there
and it'll say 2.5 million or similarly I
could say hey the formula for 52 choose
5 is math factorial of 52
divided by
math.factorial of 5 times math.
factorial of 52 minus 5 and you guys are
getting way of people reading can you
guys see that math factorial 52 divided
by math factorial of 5 times math
factorial 52 minus 5. all these three
things get you to the same answer
the factorial gives you a way to count
the number of outcomes in a much faster
way than if you had to generate every
single outcome yourself
and also I just want an excuse to show
you guys some cool code so now you know
as a computer scientist you can do this
like even cooler than the math friends
that you've got yeah
one that one
we just before like refuting for people
in the game room and outside of the case
as in distinction
in fact during the entire thing divided
by
um feeding sanctified people inside the
room which has interchangeable all the
people out there
okay and then you've done a beautiful
thing it's not very obvious but what
you've seen is you've recognized that
this combination is very similar to
ordering of dis indistinct items you
have two groups of indistinct items
people in Cape crew and people are not
capable for some of you guys this is
like totally going to be a mind flip
once you've seen a problem one way it's
sometimes very hard to see a different
way but your abs are right there is an
equivalence between those two problems
and you've seen it if you don't see it
that's absolutely fine but if you guys
want to think about a little bit more
that's a really cool thing can you
recognize why does this formula looks so
similar to ordering of items where some
of your items are indecent
and if you can flip a problem there's
always an equivalence where you can do a
combination and express it as an
ordering of distincts and distinct I
don't think that was your question you
had a different question
the 15 people who are not part of Peter
why do we care about that communication
sure sorry we shouldn't care about them
um if we're just choosing people for
cake but if you don't count them we know
we'll get a different answer than we got
from itter Tool so clearly it's an
important step in getting the right
answer
but what's going on there if you just
construct your cake room let's choose a
smaller number by the way other Pro tip
if something is hard you want to think
about choose small numbers let's say
there's six people and we're going to
choose three that's the book example so
we put three people in our cake room
and three people in our not cake room if
step one is to come up with all
orderings there's 100 or there's six
factorial different orderings
and in some of those orderings you'll
get zero you know these three people
here
and you've figured out a way to come up
with every over counting of those people
inside
but if you took any single one of those
or you had like this person this person
this person
when you generated your six factorial
you'll get every permutation of people
outside you'll get like X1 X2 X3 and
you'll get x2 X3 X1 so when you start
with six factorial
that describes the size of a huge set
and within that set there is groups
where even if you thought of these as
indistinct you've already handled that
case you will see an outcome which is
these three interesting things get cake
and these guys don't get cake and then
you'll have this outcome which looks
basically the same but you just have
treated these people outside as
indistinct is a really cool subtle
question but you do need to deal with
the fact that in our first step when we
created all these six factorials
we generated a lot of examples of
different orders of people not getting
cake
very subtle very cool question
okay
let's take our two-minute pedagogical
pause before we do that what is what can
you do during your two minute paragraph
pause you can have a good time you can
talk to person next to you but if you
want to the number one thing you could
do for learning is to try and
crystallize what we've learned try and
summarize what we've done so far before
we move into the next great topic of
cs109 okay fantastic take your two
minute pedagogical pause talk to you in
a second
okay
we have
one last thing to do today
but I wanted to sell celebrate we did
something you know kind of
straightforward we made it more
complicated this thing had a whole cake
story that was wild and we're getting
into the final task that you need to do
in counting in cs109 and that is let's
figure out how we can put some stuff in
buckets let's do it
uh we're going to be thinking about a
distinct case and then we'll think about
the interesting case
thinking about the distance
imagine you have four distinct things
and you want to put them into three
distinct buckets it turns out that this
is a little bit straightforward using
the step rule of counting
each distinct thing chooses its bucket
first distinct thing chooses buckets
it's number buckets options the next
distinct thing chooses its bucket number
of buckets because each of your objects
are distinct and each of your buckets
are distinct it ends up just being you
have all the bucket choices for the
first string this is putting strings
into buckets all the second all the
bucket choices for the second string and
all the bucket choices for your nth
string
you could have derived this from first
principle in fact if you never memorize
this rule even if it was like an exam
setting this is a sort of thing that if
you knew your step rule of counting you
could come up with but if you have
distinct objects being put into distinct
uh buckets it's just a power
so
maybe sit with that for a second see if
you can think of a good question is
there anything confusing about this
it's R times R times r n times there's n
steps and each step has R options what's
R the number of distinct buckets we have
and what's n the number of distinct
items so choice of buckets times choice
of buckets times choice of buckets and
times
okay it's going to get a little bit more
exciting though when we think about
indistinct things into our buckets
you guys ready for it
okay I'm going to close my slides for a
second
and we are going to just think about
this using physical objects oh that's
kind of interesting it's stuck on that
slide Good Times
I have myself here
four indistinct objects and I would like
to put them into buckets may I tell you
another story
because if these were distinct objects
which they are not and we want to put
them into buckets we think of each of
our buckets as different that's not too
bad because there'd be number of buckets
choices for this little fellow number of
buckets choices for this little fellow
number of tobacca's choices for this
little fellow and number of buckets of
choices for this little fellow and that
would just be buckets times buckets and
buckets buckets buckets to the power of
four
but they are not indistinct or so
they're not distinct they all look the
same so if you use that formulation you
will have over counted
I told you there's two different ways of
over counting sometimes you over count
by a fixed number you subtract it off
sometimes you over count by a
multiplicative you divide it out
unfortunately if you went about starting
with this formulation thinking them as
distinct and then try and subtract or
divide on your mind will explode
instead there is the most wonderful
creative interesting description for how
you could derive how many ways you could
put those things into buckets I am going
to introduce you to my new friends the
dividers
we're going to put those cans into well
let's say three distinct buckets if I
want to put those cans into three
distinct buckets I'm going to introduce
two new friends divider one
and divider two
and what I'm going to now do is I'm
going to
think about organizing not just by Coke
cans but my Coke cans and these two new
friends are dividers so here's one
ordering of my Coke cans and these two
dividers notice that order is a thing we
already know how to do
if I ordered my Coke cans and my
dividers like this I can interpret as
this coke can is in this bucket these
two Coke cans are in this bucket
sometimes your dividers just fall off
and you know that doesn't really get oh
you know my dividers are going to be
face down because then no one gets hurt
um
so
I have my face down dividers
it's okay it's like ten thousand dollars
worth of equipment
um but this tells you that there's this
you know one cocaine in this bucket and
then whatever between these two dividers
I think of in bucket two in this case
I've got three buckets
my claim is I can think about any
assignment of my indistinct objects into
buckets by thinking about an ordering of
both the Coke cans and the dividers
so if you gave me any ordering like this
ordering for example or you know this
ordering for example
like there's just not enough space for
you guys cook cans you're up here
you can't see it okay
here you go I have two can you see it
now
okay if I have two dividers in Coke cans
any ordering of these six objects you
give me I can interpret as Coke cans and
buckets this is how many things are in
buckets in the first bucket how many are
there
here's how many things are in the second
bucket how many are there
this is how many things are in the third
oh you guys are good what if I did this
how many in the first bucket
how many in the second bucket how many
third bucket
oh you guys are good any ordering of my
Coke cans and uh in my dividers leads to
a unique assignment of Coke cans into
buckets
but now we have a challenge
how many orderings are there
I have four Coke cans
I have two dividers I have six objects
are there six factorial different
orderings
I see some shaking ahead you guys know
that doesn't count because
four of my Coke cans are indistinct
and this is orderings with some
indistinct items how about those uh
dividers if you have two dividers like
this and two dividers like this we still
think of this as bucket zero we still
think that this is bucket one we still
think if this is bucket two so if you
just switch the ordering of the dividers
it doesn't change which Coke cans go
into bucket zero one or two
so you can think about all the orderings
of your Coke cans and you can think
about all the orderings of your dividers
and this is how many times we've over
counted
so if there's six factorial divided by
four factual divide two factorial that
is the number of ways that you could put
four objects
into three different buckets
do you notice how the number three
didn't show up there
and it's not because it didn't show up
there it in fact did
it showed up because there's not three
dividers there's two dividers
why would there be two dividers if
there's three buckets
it's a fence post bug you know if you
have six buckets you've got five
dividers if you've got three buckets
you've got two dividers because you know
there's a bucket on one side and there's
a bucket on another side
if you want to see this problem using
helmets instead of Coke cans you
absolutely can but no matter how you
derive it
there is this simple rule for how you
can count ways you can put stuff into
buckets if some of your stuff is
indistinct
you think of your n indistinct items and
you think of your R minus one dividers
and we're going to get all the orderings
of those
but then we're going to divide out the
fact that in those orderings we thought
of your n items as distinct but they're
not and then we're going to divide out
the fact that in this ordering we treat
the dividers like they're distinct but
they're not
and if you do this you end up with n
plus r minus 1 Factor I'll divide by n
factorial divide by R minus 1 factorial
which gives you the rules for how many
ways you can put indistinct items into
buckets and there you have it it's a
formula that you can use and the
derivation would be a really hard one to
do but you could figure it out if you
wanted
we're going to come back on Friday and
we're going to talk about probability
and to do a probability you need to know
this one very well you need to know this
one very well and you need to know this
one very well all the versions of
indistinct if you like this go do
problem sets and do problems one two
three four before Friday if you really
like this this is the coolest example
I've ever written about counting go
check it out and if you really like this
here's a challenge problem you can think
about between now and Friday have a
great day see you next Friday